metro police on the scene of a crash
serious injuries down in the south
valley silverado ranch and eastern
hector mohan joining us live there from
the scene hector we're told now that
fatal investigators are responding
that is correct this crash serious
enough to bring out the fatal detectives
right behind us right over in that
direction we have investigators right
now walking along the southbound lanes
of eastern
just south of silverado ranch and off to
the right that is where we have actually
have someone going through a closure
right now that is the noise we have
going on right now as we've seen before
you're seeing it live right now a
vehicle going around the police tape
even though we have the flashing lights
and investigators here all over the area
and we have more investigators walking
out of their vehicles to find out who
this person is going through the crime
scene but as we go back to the topic of
this incident what we have is
a crash fatal investigators responding
the closure we have in effect right now
southbound lanes of eastern south of
silverado ranch from what we can tell
involving this crash we have one vehicle
loaded on the back of this tow truck and
we know this happened a couple of hours
ago investigators still working to find
out more information we got a text
message from the watch commander saying
we should anticipate more information
soon that's the latest reporting live
hector mejia live local now